very good evening well we start with our
breaking news tonight and four of boris
johnson's most senior downing street
advisers have resigned this evening
director of communications jack doyle
left just hours after policy chief
monira metz quit over the prime
minister's use of a discredited claim
that the labour leader shakir stammer
personally failed to prosecute jimmy
savile and in the last 30 minutes two
more senior officials have gone they are
down rosenfield and martin reynolds well
our political editor beth rigby joins me
now so beth i know it's a it's a moving
situation but what can you tell us about
what's going on is it coordinated or are
we seeing a domino effect do you think
well i think there's i think there's
four different people and i think
there's probably two stories here one is
uh manira merza
she is and i should say to viewers
people won't know these people because
they work behind the scenes
but you know losing four of your key
members of staff in a few hours is a
bombshell going off in number 10. this
is massively destabilizing for the
government at a time when the prime
minister is already in very very hot
water but to go back to who they are and
what's going on in terms of manira masa
she is
a key ally to boris johnson she's worked
with him since 2008 on and off
you can see her coming out of downing
street there with him she worked with
him in city hall she then came back to
be
the head of policy at downing street
when he became prime minister in july
2019 and she has resigned today because
she says she cannot really in good
conscience stay by his side given the
remarks he made about jimmy savile
towards kissing well we know her
reasoning don't we because she released
that letter to the shepherd magazine i
think we've got we've got some of it
here beth okay you want to take us
through it
okay if we well there it is she says i
believe it was wrong for you to imply
this week that kia starmer was
personally responsible for allowing
jimmy savile to escape justice there was
no fair or reasonable basis for that
assertion this was not the usual cut and
thrust of politics it was an
inappropriate and partisan reference to
a horrendous case of child sex abuse you
tried to clarify your position today but
despite my urging you did not apologize
for the misleading impression you gave
so we can tell just from that you know
quite a row about that she told him to
apologize properly and and and this one
did not this morning he gave a
clarification what she clearly wanted
was an explicit apology
and with that she has left down in the
street and that was a genuine shock
because she has been such a loyal ally
so that's uh
manira and her position we then tonight
had
the director of communications
doyle resigning and in the past few
minutes the two most senior figures in
number 10 dan rosenfeld the chief of
staff and martin reynolds the private
principal secretary that's effectively
the most senior official advising the
prime minister he is the man that sent
the bring your own booze email around to
staff now all three of these gentlemen
will no doubt be implicated in the sue
grey full report when it comes out
because they have been publicly linked
to some of the events
that she is investigating so there is
clearly a question dermot were all three
of these heads go into role
when the ful when the truth outs
around the party there have been
expectations here saying all three of
them will have to step down from their
jobs
but the manner in which this is
happening is uncontrolled
you would expect the prime minister said
on monday i'm going to have to shake up
my top team i will come and bring you
the news what you have instead is a
series of resignations into the evening
on a thursday and and
it doesn't look as if the prime minister
is in control of it although
he has he instantly replaced uh didn't
he mercer he's got it he's got a new
policy chief in andrew griffith an mp an
mp and actually who formerly was a very
senior manager at sky
he has he's he's his his sort of
parliamentary aide he's made andrew his
policy adviser the statement which i've
you forgive me i i will pull up on my
phone here this is the statement from
downing street about dan rosenfeld and
martin reynolds both offering their
resignations the prime and accepting
this thanking them for their significant
contribution to number 10.
it says they will continue in their
roles while successes are appointed uh
and recruitment for both posts is
underway now it might be
that the prime minister tries to present
this and his sort of inner circle
as the beginnings of that shake-up and
that that clear out of downing street
but the manner in which it is happening
suggests the prime minister that is not
in control
uh resignations coming out of the blue
very
destabilizing and i think there's also
another question all of this dermot
if you are looking
uh into number 10 if you are a business
leader or you have a successful career
in other parts of government
are you going to want to go into number
10 and work with this current
administration given uh what is
happening there currently and the chaos
that this operation
is in and as someone that is outside
looking in but deals with these people
uh in my job
i'm looking at going well who do i go to
who do i ask questions of it really
feels like
the the ship is being deserted at the
moment and the prime minister has to try
and get a grip but it feels very very
very unstable and these are officials
but what about the politicians we
already know of at least 13 letters
having gone into the 1922 committee
asking for a vote of confidence in the
prime minister and and just before all
this started we were hearing from the
chancellor rishi sonak about the the
support for the cost of living crisis
when he was asked about those comments
that boris johnson made about
kierstarman and jimmy savile and he said
uh well let's let's listen to the grab i
was going to quote him but uh we've
actually got that from the conference
and and give us your assessment what
effect this has had
first thing to say is you know she was a
valued colleague i very much enjoyed
working with her and i'm sorry to see
her leave government on miss working
with her
and with regard to their comments
in you know being being honest i
wouldn't have said it and i'm glad that
the prime minister clarified what he
meant
being honest i wouldn't have said it now
other members of the cabinet who who
have appeared have been a bit more
supportive yeah i just literally wrote
down on my pit of paper cut and thrust
which is how dominic robb defended it he
said this was all part of the cut and
thrust of the chamber the remarks over
jimmy savile trying to defend the prime
minister what you saw there
from the chancellor
is a politician who's not trying to
defend the prime minister he's actually
trying to put distance between himself
and the prime minister he wasn't being
overtly disloyal
by actually verbally saying i don't
support him but the fact that he in
politics sometimes what you don't say
tells us all quite a lot and the fact
that he didn't give him his sort of
unqualified support and tried to defend
him tells us everything we need to know
about the way rishi sanak is positioning
trying to distance being slightly
critical actually there in fact not
slightly i took it as him being critical
and it also shows that boris johnson's
moral authority
uh with his mps and his cabinet is
draining away because russia sort of
thinks well i can and that begs the next
question which i'm going to put to you
which i already know you can't answer
because you're sitting here talking to
me which is how is it going down with
the with the with the politicians
particularly those that sit around boris
johnson at the cabinet table their
support or lack of it crucial right now
well i can tell you guys i did speak to
one ally after the jack doyle the
director of communications resignation
and manira merza's resignation
and that figure said to me
that in the case of jack doyle there's
complexities around the parties and
you know as i was saying earlier
all three of those gentlemen had other
difficulties but in the case of
manira mazza
this figure said to me well i agree with
her i think he should have apologized
and that's very telling that actually
the prime minister has had to perform a
series of u-turns a series of missteps
this week over things he said and then
he's had to change his mind
and his party are looking on saying
you're going to be getting a grip and
you are not getting a grip and you are
not changing your behavior so it begs
the question
do mps think
it's time for him to go and let us go in